let's see if we can uh squeeze somebody
else in here
what about uh you're gonna have to be
sort of quick but how about Vance from
the Atlanta suburbs Vance welcome what's
on your mind
hi David can you hear me okay yes
okay so my question is how would the
2016 election season have gone if like
Hillary Clinton was a man like
everything else about her was the same
but she wasn't a woman she was just a
man like you know it was
so close it was so close
that if being a woman cost Hillary just
a few votes in some critical States You
could argue that would have been a
Difference Maker but here's the thing I
also want to add to that Vance
there are so many single things that
could have been difference makers if
James Comey didn't do the second press
conference about Hillary Clinton if you
you know so you can play this game all
day long there are
a million different factors what was the
weather on Election Day or all these
different things
um I I think that it's an interesting
question to ask the answer is I'm sure
the outcome the the vote totals would
have differed somewhat from what they
were if Hillary Clinton were a man but I
don't know how useful as a general way
to analyze elections uh how useful it is
no no okay well uh thanks for thanks for
having me that's that's all I have all
right Vance from the Atlanta suburbs and
on that note we will call it a day for
live calls we will take calls again and
when we do I'm telling you right now
I hope to hear from you we'll take a
quick break and be right back with much
more